the craziest bachelor album advert we
finally got our answer who wasn't in the
windmill with Hannah
it was pilot Peter my body is your body
my heart is your heart get a heads up
that you had to reveal the two times in
the windmill I didn't have the heads up
in my brain yeah that that was gonna
come out yeah bachelor nation was shook
over the big reveal but now in an even
more shocking twist the fan favorite
pilot is under fire for his past a woman
who says she's Peters ex exclusively
told ET he dumped her to go on this show
Kelly Lutz claims they dated for five
months and that she found out he was a
contestant on The Bachelorette along
with the rest of America okay but now to
the real reason Hannah revealed her
windmill hook up last night her
relationship with bootp imploded when he
threatened to leave if she'd slept with
other men on the show hennas responds
yes she has and get out how did that
feel for you to kind of be forced to
reveal your sex life it was really
frustrating
so like that question was really pointed
because it was contingent on whether I
was worthy of him his love the painful
convo lasted 15 minutes
that is refusing me to get into that
vehicle really I can probably get you to
go in that limo from obviously how you
feel me you know windmill probably be
probably literally and he did but we
haven't seen the last of loop next week
he's back my heart we're talking dire
it's this is not about your heart
she said no how many more knows you need
to lay your hands and get this it's
still heated between Hannah and Luke I'm
so mad last night he created his own
Twitter account to defend his actions
saying he never meant to judge Hannah
but things got ugly as they debated sex
sin and religion at one point Hannah
clop back saying I'm not going to be
lectured on appropriate emotional
responses by a guy who threw deli meat
in a guy's lap what this is right here
this is a pile of baloney look at that
I have never met another person like
Luke I mean he's a narcissist for sure
we need to do Studies on them come on I
can't wait for next week which is also
the Bachelorette men tell all and I
heard it was really good this year
[Music]